alors rentrée 2013 ou 2014 les communes
ont arrêté leur décision pour la mise en
place de la réforme des rythmes
scolaires à 5 an en Yveline une seule
commune a choisi septembre 2013 il
s'agit de trappe les autres communes ont
opté pour 2014 comme Montini le
Bretonneux pour trois principales
raisons un déjà la circulaire est sortie
très tard ça c'est la première chose
parce que jusqu'à présent tout le monde
en a beaucoup parlé mais personne ne
savait ce qu'il y avait dans la
circulaire de la circulaire n'est pas
assez précise dans les engagements des
uns et des autres 3 la ville de Montini
a déjà voté son budget pour l'année 2013
en décembre
2012 le coût de la réforme pour les
finances communales est estimé à plus
d'un million d'euros après concertation
avec des directeurs d'école des
représentants de fédération de parents
d'élèves et des responsables
d'association de la ville des points
sont à anticiper selon le maire comme le
planning des agents techniques communaux
pour la journée du mercredi en plus de
la réorganisation des activités
sportives et culturelles des enfants le
syndicat SNUipp appelle à une nouvelle
manifestation nationale pour l'éducation
samedi 6 avril à
Paris